نعم، يُظهر الفيديو الذي تم إصداره حديثًا
رعب الحريق حيث حاول الناس
الهروب. هذا الفيديو الذي ترونه
هنا من خفر السواحل
ويظهر منظر حريق لاهينا يوم
الأربعاء، تمكنت أطقم خفر السواحل من
إنقاذ 17 شخصًا  الذين نجوا من النار
بالقفز في المحيط وإلقاء نظرة
على فيديو تيك توك هذا، يبدو أنه
يُظهر بعض هؤلاء الأشخاص اليائسين في
الماء بعد أن أُجبروا على القفز
لمحاولة إنقاذ أنفسهم من
النيران، الآن يجب أن أقول ذلك  لم
تتمكن CNN من تحديد مصدر
الفيديو أو التحقق بشكل مستقل من الفيديو،
لكن الدخان الكثيف والرياح العاتية خلقت
ما نعرفه أنه
وضع فوضوي ومرعب بشكل لا يصدق،
واستمع إلى هذا الفيديو التالي الذي
يصعب الاستماع إليه  لكنه يجسد
الرعب عندما تحاول إحدى المقيمات الهروب من
النيران في سيارتها
[تصفيق]
علينا أن نسير في مكان ما هناك بالقرب من
الشاطئ
ملغم انعطاف خاطئ انعطف خاطئ انعطف لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا ليس هكذا
ليس هكذا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
إنه لأمر مرعب أن نستمع إلى هؤلاء
الناس وهم يصرخون ويحاولون الفرار في
بضع ثوانٍ فقط،
هذه هي
شجرة بانيان تري التاريخية التي يبلغ عمرها 150 عامًا والموجودة
في وسط
مدينة لاهينا، يبدو أنها ربما
نجت من ذلك، فهي بحاجة إلى الماء  من أجل
البقاء على قيد الحياة الآن، ولكن بالنسبة للسكان المحليين
الذين ينزلون وينظرون إلى
الضرر، فهذه علامة أمل في أن
شجرتهم الشهيرة ربما
كانت ستعيش عندما اختفى الكثير
هنا ولكن التاريخ لا يمكن
استبداله هنا أبدًا.  هو أول
فندق في هاواي، فندق بايونير،
مسرح بايونير، لقد
اختفى
تمامًا هنا كانت المكتبة، وهي
الآن مجرد هيكل حجري من
الكتل المحروقة حول شارع فرونت، هناك
فليتوودز، ميك فليتوود من فرقة
فليتوود ماك، وقد التهمت النيران مكانه،
أوه،
إنه  لا يمكن التعرف على
واحدة من أكثر مدن الموانئ الساحرة المحبوبة في
أي مكان في العالم
محترقة تمامًا مثل انفجار قنبلة، إنه أمر
مدمر ما يحدث في
هاواي وما زال من المحزن للغاية أن
عدد القتلى هناك 36 ويمكن أن يرتفع، نعم
يبدو أن هذه هي الأخبار العاجلة
نبدأ بهذه الساعة وهي خارج
هاواي، نحن مجرد حرائق
غابات كارثية وغير مسبوقة، كما قال فيكتور،
قتلت ما لا يقل عن 36 شخصًا،
وعدد القتلى في ماوي وارتفع بين
عشية وضحاها، وتم العثور على جثث في الأنقاض،
ألقِ نظرة على ما تبقى  لاهينا،
إنها مدينة تاريخية تعتبر
مكانًا لقضاء العطلات شهيرًا للغاية، حيث قضى الجحيم سريع الحركة على
أحياء بأكملها
وقفز الناس إلى المحيط هربًا من
النيران، وقد غذت النيران جزئيًا
بسبب الرياح القوية الناتجة عن الإعصار، ألق
نظرة على هذا الفيديو الذي تم الحصول عليه بواسطة
ما يمكنك رؤيته هناك
هو رياح الإعصار القوية التي تجتاح
أشجار النخيل والانفجارات مع اشتعال النيران
في المرسى والقوارب، دعنا نلقي نظرة
على هذا الدمار على الأرض، هذه
مجرد فتحات في المنازل والأحياء التي
أحرقت الشركات
بالكامل  استمع إلى الناجين وهم
يصفون الوضع، حيث توجد
جثث
في المياه العائمة في
السور البحري، لقد كانوا جالسين هناك منذ
الليلة الماضية، ونحن نقوم بسحب الناس
منذ الليلة الماضية
في محاولة لإنقاذ حياة الناس
وأشعر أننا لا نحصل على
المساعدة التي نحتاجها، هذه مشكلة وطنية
في هذه المرحلة، نعم نحن بحاجة إلى الكثير من المساعدة التي
حصلنا عليها لإيصال الناس إلى هنا